we're here at the brand-new California
Academy of Sciences building with
Stephanie stone I don't want to know
what makes this building more than just
your average sized museum well for one
thing the architecture is pretty
stunning it was done by Renzo Piano and
it's also been designed to be the
greenest museum on earth everything from
solar panels on the roof to recycled
denim insulation in the walls let's
start right here just behind me is the
rain forests of the world dome this is a
90 foot diameter glass dome that allows
visitors to walk through four different
rainforests what's really fascinating
about this city is it seems like a
incredible mix of the built environment
and the natural environment yeah so the
way the exhibit will work as you're
walking in on the first floor you can
get onto this steel ramp and you'll wind
your way up through the different levels
of rainforests how you get to the top
these ramps that wind that their way
through that dome or one of the big
challenges in constructing the dome as
you can see they have a lot of complex
curves and the radius of the dome is
constantly changing so figuring out how
to bend the steel for these ramps is a
real challenge we ended up going to a
roller coaster manufacturer to ask them
to bend the steel for us and all the
steel in this building is recycled 100%
of the steel is recycled steel so what
are we seeing in this sort of space-age
piazza that we're looking at this is the
central courtyard for the academy it's
also a crucial part of the natural
ventilation scheme we don't have any air
conditioning on the public floor so we
rely on the natural environment around
us to cool the space so as cool air
drains down the slopes of the hills on
the living roof it drops in here to the
piazza then there louvered windows all
the way around the sides of the building
that open to funnel that fresh air out
onto the exhibit floor the glass that's
around the perimeter of the top here is
supported by this cable net structure
rather than by columns Renzo Piano felt
very strongly he wanted this space to be
an open space that wasn't interrupted by
columns so he used this cable net
structure to support the glass and he
said he drew his inspiration from a
spiderweb uses the same principles of
tension as a spider web so I could feel
a little bit of the hills around here
pop it out can you show us the the
living roof yeah absolutely let's just
go upstairs and take a look so we're up
here on the living roof of the Academy
it's planted with over 1.7 million
native California plants there are seven
Hills up on this roof a reference to the
seven Mills of San Francisco
the two biggest hills this one here
houses the rain forest and the other big
hill houses the planetarium dome we are
here inside the planetarium which we've
been assured will actually had seats by
the time the place opens it was it
difficult for the architect to
incorporate this really sciency dome
into sort of his overall vision and what
is he said about well this planetarium
is actually the reason that we have
hills up on our roof the building itself
is 36 feet tall in most parts of the
building that this planetarium dome has
to be much taller than that
so when Renzo is trying to figure out
how to fit the building into the park
seamlessly he wanted the building to
keep a low profile then of course the
rich had to curve up to accommodate
Fidelma morrison planetarium had to
curve up again to accommodate the dome
of the rainforest exhibit so it's really
like we've taken a piece of the park
lifted it up and then as it settles down
over the exhibit elements the roof takes
the shape of those hills
hey Stephanie what are we looking at
what are these well these are cabinets
for our store and they're an example of
the sustainable materials that we're
using in the building they're made out
of cypress trees that have fallen down
where do you get like a bunch of cypress
trees that have come down we actually
get them right in our backyard in Golden
Gate Park so clearly this is still under
construction but what are you actually
building Afrikan Hall is 21 dioramas and
they're recreated from the originals the
same taxidermy animals that were there
back in the 1930s but we've added a few
little surprises we've had some live
animals into some of the dioramas that
it's a new technology well you'll see at
the end of the hall there's a colony of
African penguins which are sure to be
favorites here
we're underneath the rainforest dome and
try to to where you can kind of look up
and see what's supposed to be a model of
the Amazonian rainforest exactly I had
to say it kind of reminds me of that
Hotel in Dubai that has this huge
underwater sort of restaurant yeah you
know that hotel was actually a problem
for us as we were constructing this
building because there are only two
companies in the world that make acrylic
for aquariums like this that hotel used
so much acrylic that there was a backlog
on the global orders of acrylic how
thick are we talking I mean is it like
it depends on the window this one's only
about four inches thick here but the
acrylic over on the other side of the
elevator of 17 inches thick the reason
that this window doesn't have to be as
thick is that the curvature of the
tunnel diffuses the pressure what I
think some of the fish are kind of
scary-looking those little guys are
actually piranhas really but they're
vegetarian piranhas so they're not very
menacing it's nice yeah